[Music]
best-selling author michael lewis is no
stranger to tackling complicated issues
in his books his latest book the
premonition a pandemic story is just out
in paperback lewis investigates why the
u.s struggled with this coronavirus
response despite being considered one of
the best prepared countries in the world
he also just launched season three of
his podcast against the rules michael
lewis joins us first on cbs mornings
welcome back how are you doing i'm doing
well thank you good to see you so you
say that we are worse prepared now for
another pandemic than we were in march
of 2020. how is that so and how can we
change that
i think it just as a
as a culture we have not wrestled with
what just happened i mean that's the
thing that it just amazes me that i
think there's like you've got to first
accept that you failed
that when you have four percent of the
world's population and 20 of the deaths
and you have more resources going in and
more knowledge and how to deal with it
that something was wrong and we haven't
actually there's been no postmortem
explaining like i mean they're weird
things that happen out there the why is
the death rate in miami triple the death
rate in in san francisco like what was
the
what worked what didn't work and
in on top of that
people have dug in their heels like like
i think in the beginning of the pandemic
the country could have been led could
have been led to a different place
instead it's is divided and if you come
in now and you try to i don't know close
schools in response to something more
dangerous wearing a mask wearing a mask
getting a vaccine you've got people's
their heels are done there's a
stubbornness there's a stubbornness so
so it there's like a
a public education thing that didn't
happen in the beginning that would be
harder to do now because people think
they know yeah but isn't it people do
know something and there are two
political strains here and some people
are valuing freedom over a pure public
health approach
there's some truth to that but you know
freedom freedom to do what do whatever
they want freedom to infect other people
yeah i mean that's not really that's a
very perverted idea of freedom right i
mean i think that it's it's
there was this false dichotomy that was
introduced very early on that we were
choosing between like the economy and
health and the truth is it was never a
choice that you let if you'd let this
thing run in the beginning the way it
ran in new york you'd have had neither i
mean that that the
constraints on the freedom actually
enable the economy to motor along a bit
so i think that like that wasn't
explained anyway all this is very grim
what was so interesting to me about this
story it's all which all takes place
kind of before the pandemic was
it's amazing the talent we had that we
didn't use like the people who we had
who were sitting in places waiting to be
actually who knew stuff who knew stuff
no you call them the experts you said
experts your words suck at telling their
own stories and sometimes they even have
trouble making the information that they
know interesting that it
quite often can be very boring so
whenever there's a crisis you say go to
the l6 person the person who's at level
six don't go to the top person go to the
l6 person who actually knows what
they're doing so this is the podcast
that's just come out yeah the rules
podcast and it's it's about experts and
it's sort of like exploring our problem
you know we're really great at creating
knowledge and as a society we're like
fantastic we're the best in the world
we're not so good at figuring out how to
use it and or even know who has it and
one of the one of our stories in the
podcast is just about this is about in
when you're in complicated systems
government agencies big corporations and
some crisis happens some problem happens
the guy it's not the people on the top
who have the answer it's it's usually
some very specialized expertise that's
buried six levels down in the
organization and what tells you you know
what's interesting is
so
why does that that person down here have
so much trouble getting what they know
up here right so you can
this is partly the pandemic story we had
people down here in public health who
knew what to do and they couldn't get it
into the heads of the people up here and
i think it's related to inequality in
that if you when you have big gaps
between one and two and two and three
yeah and all of a sudden level six
doesn't feel like they need to talk to
one yes and so
part of our problem with expertise i
think is a problem with inequality is
that the more inequality in the society
there is the harder it is for the person
who actually knows something who might
not have a lot of status yeah who might
be that's like someone no sob supposed
nobody but they're the superstars but
they're the superstars that's right and
and the trick is like finding those and
level five and we're glad that we found
you we appreciate you you're one of the
best at taking something complicated and
making it so exciting michael lewis the
paperback edition of the premonition and
season three of the podcast against the
rules is available now we'll be right
back